Is my screen visible?
Yes ma'am.
Okay fine.
So first of all, what we have to do is
the part of discussion today
will be transport setup
and the concession groups
which are created in the system.
This is your interface, login
system.
So first of all
whenever we have to do
transport setup, where is our
basic transport setup option?
Let's see, basic transport setup.
What do you have?
Here are the settings.
You must have noticed
that our basic setup is
in the settings icon.
They depend on which
section you are doing
and they will access that section and do the basic setup.
What we have to do today is the basic setup of transport.
What will be in the basic setup of transport?
For example, there is an institute.
Which buses are there in that institute?
Which pick up points are being considered in that bus?
Like there is a bus
which bus goes to which pick up points?
Where are the drop points of the student?
So that data
which we are managing
which pick up point is assigned to a student
which drop point is assigned to a student
which bus is assigned to a student.
To do that, we have to give a basic configuration
to the system.
Like this is the number of buses in the institute.
These are the points in each bus.
These are the charges in the bus
which we will set up basically.
The point is clear. What do we have to discuss?
Bhavya Tanvi.
Yes ma'am.
So how will we do it?
You have the option to set up the institute.
In this we have
an option of transport.
Whatever is the basic setup of transport
the first level setup of every session
we do it from here.
Remember one more thing.
The transport is
session dependent.
Session dependent means what?
Can anyone tell us?
Session dependent is the transport.
Session dependent.
Like session wise
like if we switch the session
then
means
the students' promote
whatever we have to set up
they are session dependent.
Ok.
Bhavya, do you know the meaning of session dependent?
Yes ma'am.
Session dependent means
very simple.
Like every session
the setup will be different.
So we will call it session dependent.
So you will go to transport.
Here you have the option.
First is vehicle.
Then there is vehicle route.
In that institute
the number of buses
the detail of each bus
is your vehicle.
You will click on it.
Ok.
Here you have the super option.
New vehicle.
I know I have this entity.
Bus 1, bus 2, bus 3
I have the details of their RC numbers.
So how to add a bus?
You will click on new vehicle.
Then you have a window open.
What is this for?
The entries of the bus
are the details.
You have to enter the details of the bus.
First comes RC number.
Like HR 0123
is the number.
You can enter that.
I am putting a simple one.
Then after that
how many seating capacity is there in this bus?
Like 50 seating capacity,
50 seats, 80 seats, 100 seats.
Total seats.
Then your tank capacity.
This is not mandatory.
Full tank capacity, GPS ID.
This is for GPS tracking.
We provide a facility
like this.
I am giving you a brief introduction.
What facility is that?
In which it is used.
We provide an option
like GPS track option.
Means student epic.
QR code kind of.
It will scan the child.
It will get the attendance of the child.
We provide an option of GPS tracker.
GPS is in the bus.
It puts the ID here.
It is not mandatory.
This is your mandatory field.
RC number, your seating capacity.
Then its insurance date,
amount of insurance company.
Rest is your non-mandatory
information.
The corresponding information
of the vehicle.
This is your information.
If you start adding this
it will give you the mandatory information.
Insurance date.
Like I am taking this for now.
For example
the insurance of this bus
is from 2 to 8.
Then the insurance date will come.
After that if you have a corresponding document
you can update it.
Same pollution certificate,
fitness certificate, road permit, road tax.
So we have a vehicle
corresponding mandatory information and documents.
We save that in the data.
Clear?
Now I am just adding
random data.
Here you will get the option
to add the vehicle.
In the same way you can
create N number of vehicles in the system.
You have added the vehicle
Still you have to update it.
You can do this.
You have to update
more information.
You have the option
to update the detail.
You can update the existing detail as well.
Then you have the option
to update the data.
Any doubts?
No ma'am.
Is it clear?
One minute.
Ok.
Let's continue.
Is this part clear?
Yes ma'am.
This is your vehicle
that you add.
You can add bus 1 and bus 2.
Now
what we have done is
we have added the data
of buses in the transport
institute.
Now in that bus
where the bus is going,
where it drops the students,
where it picks them,
all that is our vehicle route.
Do you understand the route?
The whole route of a bus
is defined in the system
in the vehicle route.
Ok.
How do we create this?
You have the option
of new vehicle route, copy from session
and then exit.
What option do we have?
It is possible that
there are many entities
that are running from the previous session.
Ok.
The previous session
means
that the previous session
has the same data.
It means that you have to copy
from the previous session.
So we can use this feature
which is the button
to copy from the previous session.
This will be used
because you will have a session list.
This entity has a single session.
If it had only 24-25 entities,
it would have come in the drop-down.
If I had selected that,
the set-up of the vehicle route
would have been copied from the previous session.
Do you understand the purpose of this?
Yes ma'am.
We have also done the BAP module
in the basic set-up,
copy from the previous session.
Yes, so you can copy from the previous session
if you have any previous
already existing entity.
Now I have a new entity
in which I have to add the vehicle route.
What is this Excel?
The data that you have here
is to export that data in Excel.
We will add a new vehicle route.
You have the option
to add it.
Now you have to add the name of the route.
For example,
I have added route 1.
Which vehicle is running on the first route?
The whole list will come here.
The data that I will give you
if you create N number of vehicles,
the whole list will come here.
You can set the route according to yourself.
Like the bus that runs on route 1,
which bus runs,
I have selected that vehicle.
Then,
you have to understand
what this means.
In the case of school,
installments are made
in case it is monthly.
You must have seen it in your fee structure.
In case it is not monthly,
it is bi-monthly.
For example,
there is one for 6 months.
It will be from April to June.
It will be for 6 months.
So all the installments are made.
We also have installments.
So,
we have installments.
You can add pick-up points.
For example,
the bus that runs on route 1
is going to Ansal,
is going to Taiseel,
these are the pick-up points.
For example, this is Ansal's pick-up point.
There are different pick-up points.
But our fees are
made in this way.
In all the installments made,
So in this case, it will not be charged in this installment.
You may know the criteria in the case of school.
In the case of school, we do not take the fees for the transport in the month of June,
nor do we assign the children in demand.
The fees for the transport in the month of June are not there.
So what will happen here?
All the installments will come by April to March.
So in that case, you will select the installments here.
And what is he doing?
After selecting that, he is defining in the setup
that whatever fees we will pay here,
the fees will not be charged in this selected installment.
Do you understand?
What is the purpose of this?
Select skip installment.
We have to skip the transport amount for the selected particular installment.
Ma'am, we can select multiple months at a time.
Exactly.
We can select for the first or second installment.
But this means that he will skip.
Selecting means that he will not pay the fees for that particular installment.
Okay.
We do this in the case of school, most probably.
If we select the month of June,
then when we assign a particular pick-up point to the student,
then in that case, the fees will not be charged from April to March.
Because we have selected the month of June.
This is the main agenda.
Then we have the select employee.
Now, you can also assign the driver of this bus.
You can assign more than one.
Now, where does this data come from?
It comes from the employee.
In our setup, you have not seen the basic employee of HRM.
Have you seen how the employees are added?
No, ma'am.
Okay.
Basic employees are added.
All the employees of the institute,
either teaching, non-teaching, driver, daily wages,
we also save their data.
Then the employee comes.
This means that the driver of the bus's list comes.
The list is created in your system.
Is it clear?
Yes, ma'am.
Then we have the pick-up point.
Like I have this bus.
Where does this bus go?
On the side of the institute,
we have complete data in an Excel format.
They have complete data.
It will be written in Route 1.
This vehicle goes.
Which pick-up points are there?
Ansel.
What is the pick-up time of Ansel?
What is the drop time?
What time does this bus reach Ansel?
At what time does it drop the students at Ansel?
That is the timing.
For example,
I put the time of 6 a.m.
What is the drop point?
It is 4 p.m.
This is the pick-up time and drop point.
It will be the drop time.
Then you have the amount.
The longitude and latitude are not mandatory.
In which case does it work?
GPS tracking system works.
We put the longitude and latitude of the bus.
It is of Google Maps.
There is no use case now.
You will know gradually.
Then we put the amount.
What is the amount of Ansel's route?
For example, 2000.
So, this is 2000.
Similarly,
add another pick-up point.
Similarly, you can add a number of pick-up points.
Now, we will add one.
As soon as you add,
it will be created in the system.
This was the option
to add the pick-up route manually.
In the pick-up route,
there are pick-up points.
If you add more than one,
it will be more than one.
Let's move ahead.
In this case, there are more options.
Yes, ma'am.
You have added it once.
It can happen later.
You have to add more pick-up points.
In that case, the same option is added.
You will edit. The interface will open.
You will add another according to you.
You will update. It will be updated.
What does it mean?
You can add multiple points.
Yes, exactly.
You can add a number of points here.
Okay.
One is done. Then you will click add.
Then you will add another.
Okay.
This was our option to add manually.
You can manually add buttons
in the system.
Then there is an option to update in bulk
via Excel.
This will be our option
to upload pick-up point.
This will be our sample Excel.
This is only because we have added
one pick-up point in it.
You will have to create a route
We create a kind of roadmap.
We can add all the points in it.
It has sample Excel.
I will show it to you.
Remember one more thing.
We don't have in-time
and out-time mandatory with sample Excel.
It means pick-up time,
pick-up time and out-drop time.
This is non-mandatory.
But if we add it manually,
it will take time.
It is not mandatory with Excel.
Pick-up point name,
amount, time.
Whatever you are adding manually,
you can add it in Excel format.
As it is, once you upload Excel,
it will be done.
Excel format is very simple.
Pick-up point, amount, pick-up time
and drop latitude.
If you have any doubts, tell us in Excel.
No, ma'am.
Okay.
This will be uploaded from Excel.
You will choose the file
which you will save.
Do you understand Excel?
You have added data in Excel.
You can update it.
You have saved it in your system.
After saving it,
you will choose the file
which is saved in your system.
It will access it.
Then you will click on submit
and it will update the data.
If it doesn't update,
it will generate an error file
and give it to you.
It will give you an error.
What can be an error?
You have not added metadata.
You have left the amount blank
or you have not added a name.
In that case, it will give you an error.
Is it clear?
Yes, ma'am.
You can export your existing data
This is our basic transport setup.
If you have any doubts, tell us.
Let's move ahead.
Not yet.
Then,
the third option is
Transport Excel Upload.
What does this option mean?
We have defined the configuration
and the number of buses.
We have defined the bus road map.
Which student
has to go in which bus?
Which student goes through which pick-up point?
We have defined that.
For that, we have the same two options.
You can assign a bus to a student
or you can also assign
data from Excel
to all the students at once.
When we have to assign data
from Excel to the students,
we have this option
Transport Excel Upload.
Is the meaning clear?
Why is it being used?
Repeat it once.
What have we done in the system?
We have defined the buses
and the number of buses.
We have defined the pick-up point
and the drop point.
We have not set a student
which pick-up point
and which bus he goes through.
We have not set that.
When we have to assign data
from Excel, we have this option
Transport Excel Upload.
It means that the student details
are there.
The student's routes are assigned.
Exactly.
The student is assigned.
This is also your sample.
I will show you.
This is our sample.
It will be visible.
Yes, ma'am.
You must have noticed
something in ERP.
The student who consists in ERP
has a unique ID.
That is reg number
or admission number.
It depends on the word used in the institute.
Reg number is a unique ID
of the student.
We update all the data
corresponding to it.
Either it is the transport,
or the student's fee demand
or any existing details.
We update the student details.
We update the reg number corresponding to it.
We do the same here.
The reg number of the student
will be the reg number.
Then the wickle route and pick-up point.
What is the wickle route?
Here we make the wickle route.
This is the wickle route.
This is the name.
Then the pick-up point.
What is the pick-up point?
Like Ansel.
I have made another one.
Like Faisal camp.
The pick-up points are different.
Which pick-up point is it coming from?
Like it is coming from route 1.
What will I keep in Excel?
I will keep route 1.
The student's reg number will be the student's.
Then the wickle route, that is route 1.
Then the pick-up point.
What is the pick-up point?
Like Ansel.
If there is another student's pick-up point,
then I will keep another one.
If there is another route,
then I will keep that route.
Do you understand?
This is the point.
We will just re-assign.
Then automatically,
in the interface of the student,
the corresponding fees
that we have created here,
will be given to him.
Is there no need for wickle number in Excel?
No.
Why is there no need for wickle number?
Because we are defining wickle number in Excel.
In Excel, the route
and its corresponding pick-up point
will be given to you.
In that case,
you will get this.
The purpose of this point is simple.
You are assigning the transport data
of the students via Excel.
Okay, ma'am.
Okay.
Then we will discuss one thing.
This was our basic transport setup.
We will discuss one more thing today.
That is concession books.
You must have seen the basic fee setup
How is the fee heads, term look,
fee group, etc.
It must have been okay from fee heads to fee group.
Okay, ma'am.
Okay.
Now we will discuss a point.
That is concessions.
We have an entity, an institute.
There are several concessions in the institute
like sibling concessions.
Other than that,
there is staff word concession.
If a student is the child of a teacher,
they also have a staff word concession.
There is third child concession also.
Like if there are 3 siblings,
Yes, ma'am.
Now, how to add a new concession in the system?
You have an option, new concession group.
Now, see how this comes.
Whatever fee you have defined in the system,
and the corresponding installments,
because the entire fee structure is going according to the installment.
So the concession won't go according to the installment.
Like, if your fee is tuition fee, tuition fee is four installments,
then the concession will also be tuition fee.
It will go to four installments.
Right?
Yes, ma'am.
So now we have to make concessions.
For example, the concession that I am making,
I am making a staff card concession.
Here you will define the name of the concession that you are creating.
Then, which fee head is the concession that is being created?
There is an option, all of our fee heads are being created.
It is being created on one fee head.
You will select according to yourself.
For example, the concession of the staff card,
their annual fees are being created on that.
And they have said that they have a 50% concession.
Like, complete fees per 50%.
So, there are two options, percentage or flat.
I have talked about 50%.
So, I will use the percentage.
And here I will list the value of the percentage.
Like, in all installments, it is 50%.
So, I have done 50 here.
In case the concession is not in the percentage,
that is, it is in the flat.
Flat means that there are 5000 concessions
for first installment only.
And there is no concession on anyone else.
So, you can flat according to yourself and add that value.
It is clear that if you add normal to create a concession group,
your concession group will be added.
This is done.
In the system, concession can be done on the staff card,
sibling concession.
Whatever is their criteria,
your concession can be done on the basis of those criteria.
Ma'am, in the system, by default,
this name, like staff board,
we have typed it ourselves.
So, by default, all the concessions
which are available,
they will come by default when you assign concessions.
For example, when I assign a concession to a student,
then I will get a list of the concessions
that are made for the institute.
Now, the name of each entity is very different.
Okay?
So, in that case, we are defining when this will come.
The thing that you are saying that it is listed,
we are defining that from here.
When we will assign a concession to a student,
then it will come.
It will come for a drop down.
One more thing,
most of the time, we also do manual concessions.
You must have seen one thing.
Sometimes, the same concessions are given.
Like, the principal said, give me 5,000.
Okay?
So, that is our manual concession.
It is up to us to give at any fee.
It is up to us, the institute,
to give at any fee.
So, we call this kind of concession as manual concession.
Okay?
I mean, it is used in most of the entities,
so I am telling you.
Manual concession.
In the case of manual concession,
we keep all the head sticks flat and then zero them.
Why do we do that?
Because this is a concession group
in which you don't know when you have to give
a concession to a student.
This, your fee-clerk,
or any person concerned in the institute,
they will assign it to a student
according to their criteria.
So, in that case, we also make a manual concession.
Okay?
When it is not defined,
they have to give a concession.
But this is not defined,
how much concession they have to give.
That varies in every student's case.
Then manual concession is required.
Okay, ma'am.
I will also tell you how to apply it.
From where it can be applied.
You have the student.
This is the student's list.
Okay?
You will click on the student's list.
Here, you have the concession fee.
Okay?
You will click on this.
Okay, the transport is also from here.
I will also tell you that.
Now, the system in which you have created concessions,
you will have the list of all those concessions.
The list will come to you.
What you were saying, right, Kanvi?
Yes, ma'am.
It will come to you.
What you have created.
For example, I have to give a manual concession.
Okay?
So, in the case of manual concession,
here, the auto-tick has done annual fee.
Why?
I have done all the ticks.
Because if you look at the fee demand,
then it is only in the annual fees.
It is not there.
So, concession will not be given.
Right?
When concession is given,
the amount will be given.
Now, here you have the option,
it is editable for you.
Means, you can give as much concessions as you want according to you.
That is called manual concession.
Okay?
Whatever remark you want to enter,
you will enter the remark.
And there is an option,
we can upload the file from here.
Like, you must have seen it.
There is an application at many places.
There is a signature on the application.
It is written on it.
So, that document.
Okay?
We can upload that in the system,
the corresponding of this particular student.
You will save it.
It will be saved.
Here, you are asking for confirmation.
We have already received it.
See, it has already received the money of the student.
So, we are giving it in this.
Let's see, in this,
let's click concession.
We will save it.
Okay?
In this also,
what is he saying?
Understand carefully.
For example,
all the fees of this student,
all the money of this student has arrived.
Okay?
And after that, I am assigning concession.
But we have received it.
Do you understand?
After that, I am doing concession.
So, what is he saying?
That we will put it in the extra fee.
So, you still have to proceed or not?
He is saying that.
Do you understand?
For example, your fees were 10,000.
Okay?
In that 10,000, you have also deposited 10,000.
So, what is your balance?
It is zero.
It is done, right?
But still, you are giving concession.
So, that money will be saved in the extra fee.
Okay?
Here, you will save it normally.
Your concession will be saved.
Just for the purpose of now being.
This is our option to assign concession.
Other than that, if it is Stafford,
if you do Stafford,
in the case of Stafford,
whatever percentage you fixed,
he automatically took it.
He fixed 5,000 flat.
So, he automatically fixed 5,000 flat.
Okay?
Now, you can see one more thing.
Here, there is an option to enter by pushing.
For example,
we have multiple of heads selected.
And there is manual concession.
In the case of manual concession,
we have to give 3,000 concessions.
Okay?
If you give 3,000 concessions,
if you push it,
your head will look at it.
In this head,
you have taken as much as you are getting from one installment.
For example, in this head,
we had a margin of 2,000.
The margin of 2,000 means that
your demand was up to 2,000.
So, it will not give 2,000 concessions either.
You cannot give 3,000.
Do you understand?
Yes.
So, it will give 2,000.
From the next head, it will give 1,000.
So, in that case, we use this option.
In the case of manual concession.
Apart from that, you can use it anywhere.
It means that you can push it.
First, you can utilize the amount.
Then, you can utilize the series according to the amount.
Okay?
Then, I told you that
we can assign a vehicle detail to a student manually.
Okay?
So, we will do that from here.
Student profiles.
We opened the student interface.
You will click on the detail.
Click on assign route.
Then, you will see a pop-up window opened.
What is this?
To assign.
Like, which bus is the route.
We have created a single route.
Which pick-up point is the pick-up point.
After that, the amount.
Here, it automatically fetches the amount.
The drop point is the same.
Select a different route.
If you toggle on the option, it will give you the option.
If it is the same, it will show the same.
Select the installment.
You have to keep it for the sub-installment.
If you assign, it will be assigned.
Here, it says, Chetan has been assigned route successfully.
It means that he has been assigned the route.
If you see here, he has been assigned the transport.
If you see here, he must have been assigned the transport in demand.
He had put his transport in 2000.
It is also in the second and third installment.
It is clear how he has assigned the transport.
We have only assigned the pick-up point and route in transport.
The corresponding amount defined in the system.
It will automatically go to your demand and get the transport amount.
Ma'am, we cannot assign the transport in bulk.
Because every student has a particular route.
We can do it in bulk.
The option we saw just now.
We have to assign it in bulk.
We use it in bulk.
Do you know what happens?
The students of the previous session are promoted in the upcoming session.
The transport is similar to them.
It can be the same in the upcoming.
Many students leave it.
But in most of the cases, it remains the same.
So, in that case, we export the Excel from the previous session.
We have the transport report section here.
You will get to know about it gradually.
The transport report is there.
Transport occupancy and transport report.
We will export the whole report in Excel.
We will keep it in the same sample and assign it in the upcoming session.
It is not done manually.
You can export it in bulk.
You can upload it.
Okay.
Any doubts so far?
No, ma'am.
Okay.
That's all for today.
Ma'am, share the recording.